Good morning Hank; it's Thursday, January
4th. I'm standing on top of Little Pisgah
Mountain in North Carolina.
That was actually recorded on Wednesday, January
3rd, but you'd have no way of knowing. I believe
that's what they call movie magic!
Hank, in your last video you asked me to continue
our discussion of our differences. I think
one of the most important differences between
us is that you are excellent at living in
a way that's commensurate with your values
where as I am not. Uh, for instance, I didn't
recycle until I watched An Inconvenient Truth,
and I'm still sorta iffy on it. And also,
uh, I didn't vote *sigh* in 2000. Even though
I could have voted in Florida. Ah George Bush!
It's all my fault! God I'm so stupid! Ohhh.
Let's change the subject.
Also, we have vastly different happy dances.
(dances) Yes!
Well, I noticed that in your last video you
completely ignored my "Eat Five Sheets of
Toilet Paper While Discussing the Political
Situation in Nepal" challenge. Let's just
admit that that was some awesome pronunciation.
And if you're not going to eat five sheets
of toilet paper while discussing the political
situation in Nepal, well, I'm going to. All
right, Green, you better do this in one take
because it's not gonna be fun.
(gags) The thing about the political situation
in Nepal is that there are these Maoist rebels
who control more than half of the country.
Who has Maoist rebels any more? Ugh. No.
(gags & coughs) I can't do it, Hank. I think
this stuff is two-ply, too. I think that was
part of the problem because if you get the
one-ply stuff, I can just oghomamamam just
down that, but this stuff? Ooph.
Oh and by the way, I have great news! Brotherhood
2.0 viewer, Peter, just had a baby. Well actually
his wife had the baby. She was in labor for
32 hours! I'm thinking maybe we should get
them a baby present. A- What, what do you
call a baby present? A baby-warming present?
Baby... shower... baby... baby... A baby present!
I was thinking maybe we could let Peter pick
a project or challenge for us? What do you
think?